hey hey comedy huh still not really sure
what this
is but uh glad to be here
yeah feels like a comedy show but it
looks like a porn shoot
just confused i feel bad for kids so
much stimulus coming to kids iphone
internet social media remember a
happy-go-lucky words kids not a care in
the world maybe run of the car
shotgun that was like the biggest
problem in my life shotgun
yeah i never see kids doing that anymore
the only time a kid yells it out now is
in a classroom
a lot of racial talk now white privilege
this term here a lot now white privilege
but i thought it was all about diversity
so shouldn't we talk about everybody's
privileges why would we just limit it to
whitey let's spread the love let's make
every group feel good everybody's got
something
tall people privileged see the concert
jews
no hell pretty good pretty good
women ladies night that's cool black
people i can't wear a purple suit
can't keep up with the terms
you know some pc i like like native
american that's good he's not from india
why are we calling in india native
american great i'll say that but like
african-american i feel weird saying i
don't mean african-american friends i
have black friends i mean caucasian
friends i have relatives
none of it adds up we're all the african
canadians why don't we say that it's
black people born cane every day we
don't know what the hell we're saying
anymore we'll be like idris elba is an
amazing african-american actor
well he's british yeah i think white
people are scared of saying the word
black we're just trying to avoid that at
all costs we don't get in trouble you
know
you could corner a white guy with a
microphone a video camera like what
color is ray charles he'd be like uh
he's blind
but what's his ethnicity piano player
what culture skin i got kids man come on
i think we're all sick of this [ __ ]
though we're all
i mean the corona is kind of like the
check engine light you know when you
first hear about it you're like damn
this is terrifying then after a while
i'm like [ __ ] i gotta get to work
i mean this is a tough time in history
for black people black people are going
through it the two people have it tough
right now are black people and women
named karen they're having a tough go
um but yeah yeah poor black people are
so strong i'm surprised i thought they'd
be fine with illness i mean look at
magic johnson he's still kicking
right he's doing great hell he beat kobe
[Laughter]
i know who saw that coming
yeah you got to live life folks yeah
i know ah black people are getting sick
i blame
institutionalized racism and elaborate
handshakes come on
i told an abortion joke recently and a
woman approached me she was like hey
that's very insensitive i've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that
i was like whoa hey sorry i just told a
joke i think what you did was much worse
yeah you gals can say a lot of stuff
like my last girlfriend dummy said i
wasn't
manly enough for her not a manly guy
that one hurt
i don't know we're allowed to say stuff
like that like i'm all about equality
but how a woman can say something like
yeah that guy was good with his hands he
could fix stuff around the house
cool but if a guy says hey i like a
woman who can cook people go whoa whoa
it's not the 50s well how come her job
for me is okay but my job or her isn't
okay
also who doesn't like somebody who can
fix [ __ ] around the house
i'd love to come home my girl was like
hey bill's a dick [ __ ] right
all right awesome i'll do laundry yeah
see i think women are you guys are so
smart because you guys made your gender
roles offensive
yeah that was very clever
well played ladies well played
guys how great would that be if we could
offend any girlfriend wake up at 4 a.m i
heard glass shattering somebody break in
you're like well it's not the 50s go
check it out
my ex-girlfriend very paranoid always
going through my phone sock drawers
sniffing me always looking for clues
that's why i'm surprised you don't see
more female detectives
ladies you guys will be amazing at that
you guys are intuitive you're curious
you're persistent
i feel like you gals would crack every
case as long as you thought it was
personal
that's the key like man this guy killed
18 people in fresno so what well he's
also cheating on your best friend give
me the file
see the problem with the phone is
there's no cut off like with booze you
drink too much somebody goes hey you've
had enough or
your body cuts you off you pass out you
just fall down
you puke phone no cut off we need like a
phone bouncer
there's a guy like hey you can't get in
you're like but that's mine
that's me it's my place
oh i heard a phone all right um
i don't know i'm just i'm way on my
phone way more than booze like i've
never been like i got to take a [ __ ]
where the hell is my cocktail
i'm going to be shooting for six weekend
of a cocktail no cocktail for six
minutes it's insane
all right all right um well keep it
moving
you look pissed
you don't believe me
that's the joke just
shut up all right we'll talk later
all right um cool all right
oh boy what the hell was that talking
about
oh yeah so yeah the gays ah but you gals
you're so sexy you're driving me crazy i
want to just want to put stuff in you oh
you're so hot with your wacky labia i
love it yeah
this is uh this is how sexy girls are i
was at the dinner once this girl leans
over during the meal and goes hey
i'm not wearing any underwear i was like
oh my god that's hot then i realized why
is that sexy
has underwear ever been a huge obstacle
for a guy has anyone ever taken a girl's
jeans off seen paintings been like
it's gonna be a long night put a pot of
coffee on i can't crack that code
that's how hot you are gals you can tell
by oracle clothing you're not wearing i
can't even see it missing i'm already
turned on yeah
doesn't work for me as a guy i can't
pull that off i lean over during dinner
hey
i'm not wearing any underwear she's
gonna go uh-oh what happened
laundry day diarrhea need a wet wipe
talk to me
seems like a lot of people are quitting
the booze now it's kind of going away
all my friends are getting sober and
look
that's good but some people are better
when they're drinking there's a lot of
bad sobers out there yeah
we always talk about the negative part
about booze what about the good like
sure you drove through a playground but
you could dance man i i try not to make
fun of fat people unless they make fun
of me
that's when i let it go you know like
all my fat friends give me [ __ ]
one of my friends told me i have skinny
privilege
like privilege something can't be a
privilege if you could do it too
ah pedophilia huh any pedophiles here
i mean statistically it's got to be two
right
but hey we're all adults here which is a
sentence they hate
ah yeah comedy
hey comedy huh comedy
huh thanks a lot i'm kevin hart have a
good night everybody thank you thanks a
lot i'm kevin hart
thanks a lot i'm kevin hart thank you
all right thanks a lot i'm kevin hart
have a good night
all right thanks a lot i'm kevin hart
have a good night thank you